good morning everyone so I'm going to
take a video of today kind of show you I
wake up they come out here we see Bernie
and we see Maisie Bernie's on the left
Maisie's on the right and Bernie's
anxious to get going good morning Bernie
hi baby girl hi said hi Maisie say hi
all right you ready come on I do you're
not ready yet all right let's go bitter
trolley look at that waddle look at that
waddle looks like you're kind of full
Bernie knows exactly where she's going
all right so yeah that sounds a little
bit nice warm water lost cloth and we
just skip a nice wipe down I'm sure
she's all clean I don't want any any
jams your dirtiness dirt anything to
fall down into our milk bed over there
another dry rag a towel just drive it
off then little loose hairs off oh ok so
got myself a little blue cup here and we
take and we squeeze a couple shots out
see oh don't quit stop okay she's really
full today so I'm gonna put down for
just a second cuz she's leaking she's
full I'm gonna unload on him today I'm
not even Ivan squeeze and she's already
pushing out from up there alright folks
i'm going to bed milk her out and i'll
say how much we have left Dante